[Musique]
comme on tient le coup
pourquoi tahiti qu'est ce qui t'amène
ici je veux vivre la grande aventure
wow c'est qui ce mec
[Musique]
ça fait quoi naviguer en solitaire
d'abord du manque de sommeil telles mal
de mer et au bout de quelques jours
arrivent les hallucinations
alors pourquoi tu fais parce que ce
qu'on ressent est incroyable ya que toi
face à l'horizon infini
cette dirait dans des lieux azaña
jusqu'en californie
tu en penses quoi qu'elle naviguait sur
6500 km c'est de la folie j'irai nulle
part 3,7 de plus vient avec moi d'amour
[Musique]
l'ouragan d'amour évolué de façon
inattendue il vient de passer en
catégorie 5 au mieux qu'on vérifie que
tout est arrivé
donc on s'inquiète
blizzard
bref ça va aller je vais m'occuper de
toi mais à des milliers de kilomètres de
la terre
ouah aérien ça donne une zone de
recherche de 4000 kilomètres carrés une
goutte d'eau dans l'océan
ya pas qu al khatib
j'ai les côtes cassées et les jambes
brisées je suis un poids mort
on peut peut-être essayer hawaï c'est
comme viser une cible mouvante à 3000 km
si tu loupes hawaï
si je loupe hawaï ont même en jeu
on peut tout faire si on veut vraiment
[Musique]
j'ai parcouru la moitié de la terre pour
tout trouvé
réparé